what happens when the super mario nes  cartridge is placed into the clockworks  an nes cartridge for the game's super  mario bros was placed into scp-914 on  the setting one to one and the resulting  output was the following an nes  cartridge for supa koopa troopas game  plays exactly like the input but with  the player controlling a koopa troopa  one of the turtle-like enemies in the  original game powerups transform the  player into either a koopa paratroopa  same but with wings or a hammer bro  larger enemy that could throw hammers  enemies are replaced with characters  identified as being from the game's  mushroom kingdom with princess peach  taking bowser's role as the primary  antagonist